you're gonna love it and you're gonna
find out who I am more to my music it's
just one of those songs where it's like
you can dance to it there's a message so
talk to me about that being your first
single and then collabing with ty dolla
sign someone moves things like a natural
fit yeah okay so this specific record I
just wanted to come out with you know
people actually vibe in and I just kind
of wanted to take it to like a party
scene yeah so that's where I kind of
took it and I felt it being a very
relatable message just because I know so
many people that turn to substances to
get their feelings out and you know it's
not healthy to bottle
[Music]
[Music]
there's just a lot of people that are
suffering in silence and are now coming
out about it is there something that you
feel like you want to that you've had
bottled up that you want to release now
I think about this all the time really
yeah I feel like it's best I just still
kind of compress it just because if I do
speak up on it I just don't know how
people will view me I really I just like
to kick some things to myself still to
this day that's why music is like the
outlet for me just because when I do
stuff into the booth or into the studio
I feel no barriers and I'm like I don't
feel like anybody can stop me when it
comes to music cuz if anything you're
gonna love it either way you along with
your disharmony girls are all going solo
and you're killing it girl like you guys
are all killing it is there like anyone
from your group they like your jamming
their music right now um
Maureen just rocked her song expectation
okay so I went over to her party to like
a masquerade party going on and I was
like wait what so I heard the record
again and I already heard it before and
I remember I think she's played it for
me before she played it with me before
before actually released okay um cuz we
always keep up being to each other so
when I actually heard it in the club and
they bumped that song her song I was
literally at all like this girl's
actually singing for her life like this
is something she's been bottling up yeah
you can finally see she could finally
showcase her talent who was the first
person to listen to your single bottled
up it would be Lauren okay just because
like I said it always had like an
exchange of like listening sessions and
she's always like pulling it out and
she's like I wanna hear I want to hear
but I'm like the type of Disick no I
don't want that you ready I don't know
if it's ready I don't know if you like
it and then she here is the kind so I
love how passionate she is and how
excited she is just genuinely and as I
am for her yeah it's an exciting moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know someone else's that's already in
the studio's Aly Brooke would you ever
go in studio with her at any point have
you or any of the 5h girls like are you
all separate completely separate I think
it'd be cool to do something together
but I think it kind of depends on genre
taste I'm a future me I know you want me
on your records girls but it'd be kind
of fun Lauren and I talk about all the
time so we'll see what happens the power
meeting was a huge success for you guys
but what was the biggest misconception
everyone had about you guys going on
hiatus um that we all hated each other
but it's funny because people don't
always know what you guys are going
through and it's some things that we
keep private we were all kind of like in
that same headspace of wanting to go out
and explore into this new era for
ourselves just because we've committed
six seven years into being in a group
when we could have consumed that time as
well for ourselves but for me personally
I speak for myself I just didn't want to
think of myself I just wanted to keep my
focus on just the girls yeah we were
just already doing so many great things
and just what that being said now is the
time to actually do that just because I
actually know who I am and I've kind of
found like a love for a certain genre
that I'm really into and kind of
creating that path of myself so being 21
and then 15 at the time is two different
so just yes huge jump what's your name
I'm Dinah Jane not only are you now a
solo artist which like pat yourself on
the back because you're already also a
great start but you're signed with LA
Reid and that must feel amazing I
remember and I'm sure everyone remembers
your audition on x-factor oh you the
field and Beyonce if I were a boy
and la recently yeah la Reed was one of
the first people that said oh I know
you're gonna be a finalist so did that
play a part in you signing with him or
what's the backstory I haven't watched
that audition since really long time so
out the only part I remember is like
while I was performing he was like pop
in his head like this and I remain such
a huge fan and then he made this comment
that I think made everyone turn their
head and what did he say cuz I'm a huge
Beyonce fan you think that that in the
Beyonce ever did but he still has that
same type same energy about me and it's
just amazing you know fast-forwarding
seven years later and we're still like
you know kind of in the same hype if
that makes sense and we relate to each
other so well when it comes to music
yeah he gets my direction and he wants
to make sure to bring it to life so he's
on board with everything and it just
feels good when someone's in your corner
and they're just as excited as you are
yeah or even more exciting because your
Energy's like really excited I think
it's more excited than I am I can
already see the growth that you've had
but how are you reinventing yourself
what do you want your new sound to be
known as I know we said a little hard B
but just like how are you reinventing
Dinah Jane I would say just being super
personal over there honestly like I said
I'm really shy so I love to journal and
the more I look back in my journal I try
my best to express into her music cuz
everyone thinks like I'm the very chill
laid-back carefree kind of girl that was
always like my attitude when I was at
the girls anytime crap was going down it
always went to me like how are you so
sure I'm calm you're so stress-free it's
like there's so much more to life than
there's a bob of allah and i don't know
it's always in my personality just very
chill but anytime stuff goes down now
I'm very aware and cautious and I'm
actually owning up to it I can't be too
laid-back
I have to own it and I accept the fact
that this is reality and not push things
away because you really have to get
through those tough times you have to
find a way to get out of it instead of
just sitting there act like everything's
gonna be fine
yeah that's about happening
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]